thank you so much Peter Thank You Bruno
the primary organizer for this program
it's really being it's very stimulating
to be here it's really a pleasure
Berkeley is such a wonderful city and
community so I'm very privileged to be a
part of it so welcome thank you for
coming I wanted to share with you some
some work from our community our field
and also in particular from my group on
trying to understand how the brain
performs some navigational computations
that'll let us make our way through this
world as we walk around so I want to
start with the nonhuman a very
spectacular example of navigation in the
animal world the animal kingdom so this
creature right here is an ant called a
category Fez fortis it lives in the
Moroccan desert where the temperatures
get very hot and the sand the the odor
traces that ants normally lay down as
they walk around are pretty volatile so
this ant has developed a strategy for
making its way around and that doesn't
rely exclusively on the Sun trails in
fact those centrioles aren't available
when it goes out foraging for food in
the daytime
so this is an example of what the ant
does so this white circle marks the home
base of the ant and if you look at this
very curvy trajectory this is the
outbound trajectory of the ant as it's
walking around looking randomly for food
and at the black circle the
experimenters have baited that location
with food so the and finds the food and
what does it do
but compute it takes its it's computed a
vector total net vector displacement
from home and it takes this beeline path
a straight path back home it's amazing
so this is an example of two-dimensional
vector calculus that is being computed
in the brain of the small creature okay
and what's also amazing about this is
that if if the experimenters pick up the
ant at this point and then put it in a
dark box and then translate it
horizontally over here just to prove
what that the ant is not actually trying
you know using any beacons or nine marks
or something close to home what the ant
does is it takes another parallel path
right parallel to that
so clearly has this vector computed in
the Ted and just runs off that vector at
that point once it gets to the place
where the home should have been okay
according to this calculation and it
doesn't find the home it then executes
the spiral search okay so it's an
amazing behavior here's a behavior of a
mammal this is this is actually it's not
a behavior this is actually an example
of the burrow system of a kangaroo rat
and this is a three-dimensional
underground burrow system so it has
these one-dimensional paths through it
and then these are like places of
overlap and you can see that it's a
pretty tortuous path there many
entrances and exits I think marked by Z
and so these animals presumably go in
there and then have access to no visual
cues or gets dark and then they have to
know how to get out they have to know
you know once they're in what is the
shortest exit out presumably so they're
somehow have a map of this burrow in
their head and can also calculate how to
exit this this maze there many other so
examples of amazing navigation in these
in the animal kingdom abound
so among the last characterize sort of
on the neuroscience level are these
tremendous examples navigation by that
we can at least read about in popular
accounts on migration so you know
hummingbirds we know go all the way from
you know another another in u.s. or
Canada down to Central America whooping
cranes migrate you know between Canada
and Texas monarch butterflies do a three
generational round-trip navigation so
they hatch fly from Canada to California
California to Mexico and then the next
generation so that that's two
generations and then Mexico back to
Canada as another generation so it's
like three generation round-trip and in
fact the amazing thing is they're not
just going to some random spot in these
countries actually I live in Santa
Barbara for some years as a postdoc and
they find their way to specific groves
of you know four trees right so it's a
pretty highly targeted navigation so we
don't know so much about the substrates
of these spectacular journeys but we do
know something about the substrate of
some of the other
animal navigation strategies so okay so
just to again rub it in a little bit
more that you know navigation is a
pretty amazing thing you know even for
humans right as a species a lot of our
technology has been developed in the
service of navigation so you know for
doing accurate navigation in the absence
of landmarks for example for seafaring
you know we've developed things like
compasses and sexton's subsequently
developed clocks as a way to tell
longitude and then more recently you
know we've used things like this device
that's probably on most of your car's
GPS system which makes navigation
certainly seem a bit easier than it did
before but of course we have to keep in
mind that you know it's made possible by
a lot of technological development like
you know a satellite that fly is ten
thousand miles above the earth and in
constellations of dozens and with big
rockets that actually bring those
satellites up into space right so
there's a lot of technology that goes
into making navigation feel simple okay
by at the same time right humans and
animals were able to perform pretty
impressive navigational feed without
landmarks even with you know pretty good
accuracy over the distances that are
relevant to us using not much more but
our own senses right and so the rest of
this talk is going to be about how some
of the circuits in the brain are thought
to make this possible okay so here are
some of the computational problems of
navigation the challenges to speak so I
already showed you the example of the
ant it's doing 2d vector integration
right so 2d calculus so integration
means you take an estimate of your last
location and then add to it or
incremented by your motion in the last
time step to come up with an estimate of
your new position right so that's that's
integration and clearly because it's
incrementing a previous state it
requires memory requires memory on the
time scale of minutes tens of seconds
minutes and on the other hand neurons
themselves are individually leaky or
memory lives the time constant or
revision and a single neuron can
remember anything is about 10 to 100
milliseconds so how these very leaky
are able to do this kind of memory
intensive operation is the challenge to
understand okay next we know from the
field of robotics that if you if you try
to navigate localize yourself in a space
your sensors are always noisy any
physical implementation of a sensor is
noisy so your velocity estimates are
noisy and so it's important to emerge
you know cues from the land from
landmarks in the world for whom for
which you have some coordinates and then
fuse that information with the noisy
motion based estimate of position to
improve the estimate and we know from
our friends from robotics and computer
science that these kinds of problems
really require probabilistic strategies
or at least benefit a lot from
probabilistic strategies so the question
is how does the brain do that kind of
thing
mapping of new environments so it's
finding coordinates to objects in the
world or landmarks in the world so that
you can do this and what we hear is the
mapping problem and then there's
problems of goal selection you want to
select where you should go in the world
and then once you've selected where you
should go the question is how do you
plan your paths to actually construct
the path that brings you there right so
these are all different aspects of the
problem with navigation today I'm mostly
going to talk about the integration
problem and but you know the field and
various people here at Berkley both in
our program and also at the University
permanently and people in my group are
working on many aspects of these other
problems I hope I can just mention them
at least towards the end so but I hope
to just convey that it's you know
there's there's a lot of interesting
problems and it's a pretty really rich
and interesting area okay so all right
so what are the neural substrates for
some of these behaviors navigation so I
want to show you this very complicated
circuit diagram partly to intimidate but
mostly to point out that this was
actually a plot this is a very famous
diagram made to describe the visual
hierarchy so you start from low level
sensors in the retina and it goes all
the way up to you know visual cortex v1
higher levels of visual processing and
actually this whole visual processing
pathway ends up in the in these two
areas called ER
I'd see these spent for intramural
cortex and hippocampus okay turns out
that these two areas are the the central
areas that are that show cells with
responses specifically tuned to spatial
variables and you know have been like
identified as key parts of the
navigation circuit in in the in
mammalian brains okay so so although
it's at the top of this you know big
hierarchy related to vision you know
these areas are actually multi associate
association areas so internal cortex in
the cortical area receives input from
all these sensory areas auditory visual
vestibular all of these cues come in and
then they're also all channeled through
this ntarama cortex into the hippocampus
which is the central area for learning
and memory okay
so let's just focus then on that top
area and I'm just going to show you some
regions these names probably those of
you are not in neuroscience I don't
expect you to remember them but I just
want to give you some road map so
there's the thalamus which is believed
to be sort of a pathway for sensory
input to come in to the rest of the
brain and within the thalamus there are
cells called head Direction cells I'll
tell you about these inputs go to the
internal cortex which is this big
association area in cortex and enter
around the cortex contains a lot of
spatially related responses which I'll
describe and then enter a neural cortex
connects to the hippocampus which has
many different sub structures two of
which are CA 3 and CA 1 and both of
these areas contain cells called place
cells which I'll also describe and now
this area projected back to enter a
neural cortex in a reentrant loop ok so
what do the what do the cells look like
in these areas ok so I want to describe
I wanted to show you pictures of
responses of these different cells and
then we can talk about why do you look
the way they look and how it is possible
to build models of them okay so this is
Hecker action cells all right what I'm
showing you here are the responses of
neurons the firing rate of a neuron
versus the angle of the head of an
animal a rat well in this case this is
this is data from a mouse as it's
running around the room and the angle
variable here is angle
reference to some external you know
anchoring cue okay so some external
reference so it's not with respect to
the body but respect to the external
world okay and these are you know many
different neurons um twelve different
neurons and you can see that you know
different neurons have a preference for
firing at certain head angles this one
fires at a head angle close to zero
degrees and this one fires at a head
angle close to PI okay and uh all the
way almost all the way around and so on
right so they have these different
so-called tuning curves that's what
these shapes are these these curves of
very preferred firing to certain values
of a variable are called are called
tuning curve so this is the mean
response of the cells to the values of
the variable so these amazing cells are
called for obvious reasons head
Direction cells and hydration cells were
discovered in the late in the mid
eighties and then published in the in
the nineties okay so the next bit of
cells okay so these these are these
hydrogen cells are found in the thalamus
and also in a hippocampal related area
called The Post's immaculate so now if
we go into the hippocampus
it contains cells called play cells and
so here's the experiment again so
there's a animal running around you know
room with maybe some some feature that
tells me on mo you know gives a compass
reference animal runs around but
otherwise locally the floor is
featureless in the space and this is a
recording of a single cell so each dot
is a spike emitted by one neuron and all
the spite all the dots here come from a
single neuron and you can see that this
neuron only fire is at one location or
one neighborhood in this whole room
which is over here okay so for very
obvious reasons this cell is called a
place cell so that's one place though
but we can look at an ensemble of play
cells and you can see from this ensemble
that different cells do similar things
but they have different preferred
locations right so the cell fires over
here and the cell tends to fire down
here etc so as a population they seem to
tile the space okay so you can sort of
look at which cell is active and once
you've characterized their tuning
curves then you can post facto given
spikes from this population of cells
decode or estimate where the animal is
in space then there are other cells
these are found in the internal cortex
and these cells are called border selves
and these border cells tend to fire in
at certain borders in the environment so
this is a South border cell so this is a
cell that likes to fire at the southern
border of it sort of every southern wall
in so this is a cell that's firing at
the southern boundary of the environment
but it's also firing you know at the at
the edge of this is an obstruction set
down in the middle of the environment
and then the cell is firing sort of over
here just north of that boundary as well
okay so so these so these cells are
called border cells and I'm not giving
you an exhaustive listing of all the
cell types in fact there are other cells
that are called landmark identity cells
and landmark location cells these cells
fire for you know discreet
you know localize lat works in
environment okay and in addition to all
of these cell types are also mixtures so
they're cells that fire to mixtures of
you know location place and direction of
movement or place and head direction etc
okay so they're they're mixtures and
combinations of these cell types and so
I just want to give you some of the
prominent feature business so this cell
type is one that's very near and dear to
my heart
these cells are called grid cells and
grid cells are located in the internal
cortex and once again this is a
recording of a single grid cell in the
internal cortex and if you look
carefully you'll see that like place
cells these cells have spatially
selective responses but unlike place
cells that fire multiple locations okay
here and here and here and here and
moreover these locations are not random
but they're arranged on the vertices of
a triangular lattice in fact a regular
triangular lattice that tiles all of the
available space where the animal lives
it's a remarkable really really
remarkable code so these cells are found
and you know specific layer in the
internal cortex or at least they're
dense and it specifically an internal
cortex and though they're found across
a lot of mammalian all the mammals that
have been studied exhibit grid cell like
activity so mice rats bats monkeys and
humans so across a very diverse set of
the mammalian Jacob okay so so that was
one grid cell right we can ask you know
what happens to a grid cell tuning you
know that that period that spatial
periodicity of the grid cell response is
that determine extrinsically by the
properties of the environment or is it
an intrinsically determined quantity the
period and it turns out that the grid
cell period tends to be intrinsically
determined so this is the same cell
recorded in a small in a large
environment and you can see that the the
the the period of the response is
unchanged it does not scale with the
environment size it really is some
intrinsically determined quantity maybe
look at ensemble of cells recorded
nearby each other on the same tetrode
for example the same bundle of wires
next to each other then they tend to
have identical periods so these are
three different cells and three
different colors and you can see that
and they're just this is their fields
and we can just rigidly translate in 2d
their responses and then they overlap so
basically these cells have the same
period they also have identical
orientations and they differ only by a
two dimensional phase shift so just
translations or rotations of the basic
periodic response okay so these are some
of the important players in the spatial
navigation circuit and I want to try to
discuss two questions related to these
cells that I've told you about one
question is going to be more of a
question about mechanism right this
question about how these cells that have
very short term memories individually
can can do analog representation they
can have memory and they can do
integration of velocity input okay so
that's like a mechanism question the
second question I want to ask is really
related to these bizarre tuning curves
of grid cells and try to explain what
the properties are of this response and
why fell exhibited these periodic
responses to location okay so so if we
think about so let's start with the
question of mechanism and let's think
about also representation okay so if we
think about the state space or the
activity space of n neurons okay it's
very high-dimensional so
the activity space of in neurons and
this axis our one axis is the firing
rate of neuron 1 R 2 is the firing rate
of neuron 2 R 3 is the frame rate of
neuron 3 and so on so if there are n
neurons in the circuit then there the
instantaneous activity of neurons in
that circuit is represented by one point
in a high pin dot n dimensional space
right so it's just one point in this
high dimensional space so so that's what
I'm showing you here so you know you can
you can take the system and prepare it
in a state say put it into the state
over here where you know neuron our 1 is
firing a bit neuron R 2 is firing a bit
neuron our 3 is firing a bit so you're
here the problem with that is that if
this is an unconnected neurons then if
you're prepared in the state very
quickly thus able decay back to the
origin which is the non steady quiet
quiet state because these neurons don't
have a long memory right so it's
basically all the activities are just
decaying and then this this vector or
just decays to the origin it within 10
to 100 milliseconds ok so you've got
this large representational space you
know it's n-dimensional or if we
discretize the number of states along
the axis and we've got order Q to the N
States but the problem is there's no
memory there's nothing that the circuit
can do that's interesting
ok so now if you take the circuit of
this group of neurons and now you
connect them with some specific
connectivity so in this case it's
actually a symmetric matrix with with
very strong connections between neurons
something like this like a hapa network
for those of you know hopfield net works
then it's possible to actually create
fixed points or stable states of the
dynamics and so now all of these states
are now fixed points and so they're
stable
ok and in other words there persist
right so they they okay so so so that
means they persist so they're you know
you can prepare the system in the state
and lastly ok so the cost of doing this
is uh you know now you've gone from you
know ordered Q to the N States or some n
dimensional space to going from n to 0
dimensions or from Q to the N States to
order n States it turns out you can you
know create n such fix points you can
control those and that's it now you have
a big loss in this capacity ok but you
haven't invented and the advantages that
you've created these persistent for
memory states right so these are fixed
points of the dynamics and so now you
know if you put the system in the state
it'll stay there and I'll remember
in this state other than in that state
etc okay so now you've created these non
decaying states that can hold a memory
okay and another advantage of this you
know of this of this process for this
creation of these fixed points is that
there's some noise tolerance so it turns
out that these fixed points have some
basins of attraction and so small
perturbations away from these states
also decay back to these states and then
and then corrected so the perturbations
are noise you know it's corrected in
these systems similarly it's possible
okay to create very special weights
weight connectivity matrices that are
also symmetric but have some kind of
special symmetry in this case a
translation invariance okay these two
weight matrices if they have this
symmetry then instead of creating just a
single fixed point it's actually
possible to create a set of fixed points
associated with the symmetry so in this
case because it's a continuous symmetry
group it's like rotation or translation
invariant then you can create actually a
continuum of fixed points with the same
kind of symmetry right so in this case
you can create a whole ring of fixed
points and these kinds of networks are
called continuous subtract networks with
continuous attractor dynamics they
contain this continuum of excellence
okay in this case I've drawn a
one-dimensional ring but it's possible
to do it in other ways okay so so
basically the basic principles are to
create these memory States right for you
know in this case analog representations
first you need strong connectivity to
create stable or persistent states
secondly you need some kind of
continuous symmetry in the connectivity
okay and if you have this continuous
symmetry you'll be reflected in the set
of the of the fixed one okay and so and
then finally if you add now some
perturbative so you add a slight
asymmetry to the wave now and you couple
those asymmetries to external input okay
then these you know coupling of these
wait is a symmetry is to some vector
input allow those vector inputs to push
the spades along this continuum of fixed
points okay so I'm not going to describe
in detail how that works but that's just
a high-level picture
okay so largely symmetric connective
for pattern formation for you know the
creation of these fixed points and then
some perturbative eight eight symmetries
to allow motion along to explore along
this set of fix points so let me be a
little bit more concrete since that was
really abstract let me tell you some
very concrete implementation in fact to
get like grid cells so imagine that
we've got a sheet of neurons it's two
dimensional cortical sheet and let's
just focus on this neuron over here so
this is dense and neurons I'm just
highlighting one and if this neuron has
let's oh I'm sorry that this is not
rendering very well but I've basically
drawn a doughnut of inhibitory
connectivity around this neuron okay and
suppose so suppose that every neuron in
this network has the same connectivity
to its neighbors so basically a donut of
inhibition around it then so so the
neuron is suppressing activity in the
neurons and this donut around it so then
what happens if these weights become
strong enough it allows you know it
destabilizes the the uniform activity
state in this network and allows a
pattern to form right through some
linear instability process and actually
what you get through this instability
process is a pattern of periodically
spaced activity bumps in this cortical
sheet okay and because the interactions
are isotropic or you know symmetric
around this way then you get a straggler
at lattice rather than you know if it
were not quite isotropic it might be
square or some other geometry okay so
strong inhibition around this round with
translation variance every neuron
connects the same way to every other
neuron in the network gives rise to this
you know periodic activity pattern and
in fact there's nothing special about
this specific pattern alone all
translations of this pattern are
equivalent fixed points of the dynamics
right so this activity pattern is stable
then so is the shifted version of this
activity pattern because there was
nothing special about you know any
origin in this right that were these
translations very okay so now if we look
at the state space picture again like
we've seen previously for the hospital
network or for the other network then
actually in the state space where again
you have activities of neuron one two
three etc in the state space then the
set of fixed points of this of this
network lie on the surface of this torus
and this pattern here over this
particular phase is one point
the set of fix points and all
translations 2d translations of this
pattern okay are also equivalent fixed
points and because this pattern is
periodic once you translate by one
period then it comes around and that's
why it's periodic in more dimensions
that's why it's a torus okay and so now
if you have this lightweight asymmetries
that i talked about and i'm not going to
describe in any detail but I can tell
you later
then if then if there's a velocity input
then that velocity input manages to
couple to these wait eight symmetries
and then takes this pattern here and
then starts translating it so if there's
a velocity and puts a rightward then it
takes the pattern phase and drives the
phase rightward so then a neuron that's
over here is sitting here in the
cortical sheet is active then gets
inactive inactive and active and
inactive again so that's how one gets
then in this way if one's recording from
one neuron here and the pattern is
moving as the animal moves in real space
then the cell turns on off on off on
again and then one gets this kind of
spatial response pattern over here okay
and now you know so there's a bunch of
model of this flavor of grid cells and
it turns out that these models predict
that the responses in grid cells should
be first of all there should be a
discrete set of these periods because it
takes a collection of neurons to form
one of these networks and then all the
neurons in this network will have
identical period and identical
orientation okay so as a result one
would predict that there should be a
whole group of neurons with equal period
equal orientation and then a separate
group with the different period in
orientation etc and indeed that's what's
found in the experimental literature
it's a discrete set of periods maybe no
more than five or ten okay at most ten
different periods also the prediction is
that cell cell relationships be
extremely stable so if a pair of cells
are in two adjacent activity bumped then
that means they're Co active and the
prediction is they should always be Co
active because they're the the co
activity is a function of connectivity
in the network and as long as
connectivity is not changing they should
always be Co active so in experiments
where you put animals in a familiar
environment in a novel environment the
actual tuning curves change so the
period of the response changes a lot so
so there's a rescaling of the period of
cell one and cell two but if you look at
the ratios of the periods and we look at
the South cell relationships all of
those are preserved exactly as you would
predict from these models in addition if
you record cells in one-dimensional
environments their responses look pretty
a periodic but but nevertheless can be
explained by just linear slices through
the 1 through the 2 D response pattern
so so in a sense these grid cell
responses and 1d environments are
actually quality crystals right so these
are these are like the more Penrose
quasi crystals because these are really
just you know irrational angle slices
through a periodic lattice so so we've
got quasi crystals in biology in
neuroscience as well but again this is
consistent with these low dimensional
you know periodic models of the grid
cell response and moreover the
relationships that are seen in waking so
correlations as a function of spatial
phase scene and waking in grid cells are
also seen in in sleep and grid cells so
these are different states waking REM
sleep and non REM sleep and by contrast
hippocampal plays cells do not preserve
these relationships ok so really there's
something intrinsic in the circuit
according to the data exactly as
predicted by the models that you know
keeps these responses very rigid and
preserved with relationship to each
other ok there's a continuous attractor
model also like this for head Direction
cells so 1d version
so imagine arranging neurons on a line
okay on us on a ring on a physical ring
and these neurons
once again they excited these guys
excite their immediate neighbors and
inhibit everybody else around them every
neuron does the same thing and on the
right we'll plot the state space of the
of the network here and what we'll see
is if the connectivity strong enough
again the uniform activity state is
destabilized a bump of activity forms
and then there's nothing and then that
bump is just a point here in the state
space and another bump shifted over is
an equivalent fixed point of the
dynamics and so we can just write it as
another point over here and in fact
again this whole continuum of fixed
points related by translations or
rotations around the ring are equivalent
and so now one has created we've created
a one-dimensional ring attractive okay
and then states like this are not stable
in the dynamics and so they just
represent this gray area okay so here
once again the state space picture we've
created this and then velocity input
comes and moves you around along the way
okay the appropriate coupling and so
actually very recent we've had some very
recent work validating some of these
grid cell models in data and so this is
actually neural data from tens of
neurons from the head Direction circuit
embedded in some intermediate
dimensional space and you can see that
the responses of the circuit lie on just
a one-dimensional ring okay in the
balances and so here we've colorized it
by you know some latent variable along
the ring and and it actually matches
very well to measured head directions
and in this plot you can see that
actually blue are the waking states of
the network and in green are the states
of the network during REM sleep and
those like right on top of each other so
what we can learn is that during REM
sleep the circuit maintains the same
states that it had during waking and
this is it this the circuit seems to be
encoding this one-dimensional variable
of head direction and nothing but head
direction right as far as we can tell
okay so that's a summary then of the
dynamics part of what I wanted to tell
you which was that the tuning of head
Direction grid and place cells to analog
variables can be well modeled as
emerging from a pattern formation
process and a network that possesses a
continuous symmetry in the connectivity
and there's data to you know there's a
lot of data now in support of this idea
and these form patterns are low
dimensional attractors of the network
dynamics and they can act then as robust
memory or representational States and if
they're coupled with a velocity input
from any metric space they can become
integrators for movement through that
metric space so I won't have a chance to
tell you but it turns out that some of
these cells
playstyles and grid cells seem to be
able to represent and take off changes
in other metric spaces like tone space
so you can imagine sitting in one place
but moving or using virtual reality to
navigate through some space
with varying pitch over time and then
these cells grid cells can form grid
like periodic patterns as a function of
where you are in pitch in K so once
again it's the idea that if there's a
velocity signal from any metric space
these cells can then now come to
represent positions in this metric space
abstract metrics so I think it's a
really powerful understanding of how the
brain can construct these codes for
metric variables okay so now I we get to
ask this question about coding right so
I tried to talk a little bit about
mechanism but the real question I want
to ask is why why is the brain selecting
these particular ways to represent this
information right just like I can
represent a number in many different
ways I can hold up fingers I can write
hash marks on the wall like a prisoner
would or I can write you the you know
Roman numeral system or the you know the
decimal system and there's many
different ways to represent information
why is the paint choosing these specific
representations and specifically why for
grid cells is the brain using this very
non-local periodic representation for a
very quantitative
a periodic and local which is position
right why is it doing this and and why
are there these two different
representations of location if they're
placed cells while they're also grid
cells okay so two ants to try to answer
these questions we have to talk a little
bit about information encoding in neural
populations okay so um this is notion
population codes are the information
represented about a variable in a
population of neural responses and this
is a standard way to deal with
population codes and understand
information population codes so we plot
a bunch of tuning curves for a bunch of
neurons as a function of the stimulus
theta then what neurons do then is on
any given presentation of the variable
theta the neurons respond with some
number of spikes which tend to be
Poisson you know with the rate given by
the tuning the underlying tuning right
so the the the blue cell fires at this
mean rate given by you know this point
on this blue curve here but with some
spread right at some course on our
number of spikes and so now you know
given
some spikes from a population of neurons
the question is how much information can
I extract about the actual stimulus that
they're representing and so you know so
you can do that you can plot five counts
versus the preferred angle and you can
plot those counts over here and then you
get some you can fit some curve through
that and then that gives you some
estimate of the angle theta and then but
there's of course some play in that
estimate of the angle because these
spikes are you know put onto each I can
do the measurement there's gonna be some
some some some variance and the question
is how much error does one get okay what
is that delta theta as a function of the
number of neurons in the system okay so
if many neurons fire together clearly we
have some sense that you know by
averaging we should do better have a
more sharp estimate of the angle they
know so just to quantify that let's say
there's a actual stimulus theta it's
converted into the spiked count vector
of all these neurons and then one has to
make an estimate theta hat and the mean
squared error is the deviation between
the actual value and the estimate
squared and the model for the neural
response is going to be that each neuron
fires according to its turning curve or
Poisson number of spikes okay and each
neuron spiking is iid given its tuning
curve so now we know we can compute
things like Fisher information of this
code and so the Fisher information
scales like the number of neurons
divided by the range or which these
tuning curves are laid out so you know
if you have a big range you have to take
the same number of tuning curves and
kind of spread them out to all fit in
the range so you know as the range goes
up the Fisher information goes down but
Fisher information grows linearly with n
for these uncorrelated neurons and the
mean squared error through the Kramer
round is bounded by the it's bounded by
the Kramer al bound and so it's bigger
than or equal to R or okay so in other
words the squared error in the estimate
goes down like yeah okay so you get a
polynomial gain and accurate P so
accuracy we can think of its inverse
mean squared error it with n ok so I'm
going to call any code that exhibits
this kind of polynomial gain and
accuracy with n as a classical
population could in fact most neural
codes that we know about are these
classical population codes so for
example I showed you head Direction
tuning this is this is the cell it's
just plotted as a function of direction
and firing rate these are cells in
visual cortex orientation to in cells
these are plays cells you already saw
these are cells in the motor
motor system that control horizontal
gaze position I position all of these
cells if you analyze them under these
similar models have these classical our
classical population codes because they
exhibit this polynomial gain it accuracy
with number neurons okay so the question
I want to ask is is this really the best
use of the neural currency that you're
putting it the number of neurons you put
in it was the best that you can do by
pulling together your neurons okay and
so to answer this question let's look at
this quantity called information rate
Rho okay we just defined to be the ratio
of mutual information in the code about
the variable that you care about divided
by you know the total amount of bits
used in the code so in this case I'm
just gonna have to let me have likes a
binary neurons there just find ones or
zeros and so the you know total number
torille information is or entropy is
like n because it's it's it's like log
of to the N and then mutual information
we know actually for these simple codes
the posterior distribution is unimodal
and for this you know model posterior
distributions it turns out that mutual
information is related to Fisher
information through the log of the
Fisher information so it'll go like log
n whose information rate goes like log n
over N which for large n goes to zero
okay so this is a code that has a
vanishing information ring okay and so
the question is alright well you know
you're gaining accuracy and you're of
course your information rates going down
and so so maybe this is the best we
could do but let's forget about hearings
for a moment nuts you know is it
possible to do any better and many of
you in the audience who are you know
from engineering or computer science of
course know all about you know China
information theory but I like to put
this in in case we have a diverse
audience
so of course pre 1948 we thought it was
impossible if it's believed that you
know if you want to have you know gain
an accuracy you have to do it at the
cost of you know asymptotically you know
diminishing information rate but of
course Ben Shannon proved that it's
actually possible to have a finite
information rate while reducing the
error probability to zero in the case of
discrete code so he said you can achieve
asymptotically zero error rate and find
out information rate for discreet codes
and I think for analog variables the
corresponding statement is that it's
possible to achieve
X
naturally vanishing error sizes at
asymptotically finite information so so
that's so that's what we know couldn't
be possible in theory right in in you
know in representing information and so
the question is it does the brain
contain such codes right because clearly
the classical population of which most
codes are don't don't achieve this okay
so this brings me back then to the grid
cell code okay so let's try to formalize
the grid cell code to be able to say
something about its information capacity
and let's do it this way okay so I've
just shown you a 1d version of grid cell
codes so blue cells are these you know
period they're firing it period lambda
and so are these other two cells same
period so they belong to that same
network or the same module right they
have the same period same orientation
okay but they just differ by phase right
of their preferred their preferred
location these these like it here these
like it here and he's like it here so
when animals running around in
exposition eggs
these cells are firing periodically and
so given the response of a neuron for
example if you know that this blue
neuron is firing maximally and these are
not then you know something about where
the animal is in X but only up to this
periodic variable right so it so you
don't know you only know it as a modulo
with respect to the period so in other
words the information that you can get
from the whole population of neurons the
whole group of them that share a common
period is just position as a phase
modulo lambda that's it
okay the whole populations can being a
phase okay now I didn't tell you yet
that actually oh no I kind of did I said
that they're actually you know a few
different networks that have different
periods okay in this in the circuit so
there are as you go anatomically through
this area called medial internal cortex
along this direction there are groups of
cells that have a given period another
group that have a slightly different
period and so on
and in fact if you look at the range of
periods they're about again five to ten
distinct periods but the periods only
span about a third of a meter up to a
meter and a half okay
so it's a very narrow range right that's
like not even a decade in scale right
they span this very narrow range oh and
it's much much smaller I should note
then
native range of an animal right so over
the course of a day an animal like a rat
runs around a hundred to a thousand
meters per linear dimension looking for
food coming back home etc okay so these
skills although they're multi periodic
are nowhere near the range that you
would want to be able to uniquely encode
position okay so anyway to abstract the
code out so we've got you know a vector
Phi which is the set of n phases each of
which is a modulo of X with respect to
the period lambda one under two its I
don't have to land it right so we've got
a set of n numbers okay or two n numbers
in the case of two dimensions that
specify these n phases instead of
specifying X directly okay and so to
tell you about this range you know
there's this really interesting paper I
had to look through like pest control
literature to find out in fact what is
the range it's not something you're a
scientist characterized because you know
our labs are not so big and so you know
but pest control people really study you
know how far rat is gonna go and in fact
this is an example of a rat swam ashore
from one island to another to colonize
the other island it swam across 400
meters of open water and then it
traversed an entire island 9.5 hectare
Island before settling in a home range
of about a hectare or 100 100 meters as
defined by radio telemetry right so this
is to show you what the rough you know
ranges are that we were talking about it
were rich in animal kin can find its way
okay so this grid cell code it's kind of
like the analogous to my walking into a
room and I see instead of a single clock
that tells me in the time of the day
like 8:30 p.m. or am you know okay up to
that modulo 12 correctly what time it is
instead of encounter a whole wall full
of clock the whole Bank of them with
very small periods 9 minutes 10 minutes
11 minutes etc up to 17 minutes right
and and somehow from this I am supposed
to use these clocks and reconstruct the
time of the day in a 12 hour cycle right
and that's what grid cells are doing
with respect to space and the question
is why
okay so let's do a series of
observations for this code so let's so
some of the properties of this Kopitar
first of all this code has a
combinatorial capacity so if X is
represented instead by a set of modulo
remainders let's just consider simple
idealization that's what's considered
that X's and lambdas are whole numbers
everything carries over to real numbers
okay conceptually and qualitatively
everything carries over but if you know
but you can talk about you know some
more number theoretic codes when you
talk about you know these as integers so
if let's consider just two periods
lambda of 3 and 4 and if X goes from 0 1
2 3 etc then lambda goes from 0 0 1 1 to
2 2 0 3 this one has wrapped around and
then 1 and then now the for period has
wrapped around etc right and we know we
can see here clearly that you get a
unique representation all the way out to
12 or in other words the product of 3 &
4 okay and so the code the the the the
range or you know the the the unique
range of this code is like the least
common multiple it's like the product of
all the lambdas out there if they're
co-prime and if they're not core prime
it's the least common multiple and in
fact that scales like if if all the
lambdas are approximately the same size
it scales like lambda some
characteristic lambda to the N power
okay and this is also true you can
define this for real numbers you can
just define a resolution etc and it
carries through that there's an X in the
exponent the other special thing about
this code so this is like a number
system right I mean we know so this is
like decimal number system if you have
you know six registers you can represent
number as big as you know 999,999 right
using only just six numbers so it's like
that it's just like that it's like the
decimal system it's like a fixed base
number system but it's not actually this
is called a residue number system okay
some of you may know this in computer
science and the residue number system
has some very interesting properties
beyond what the fixed base number system
has okay so the comedy's capacity is
common to fix these memory systems but
this is a property that's not common
okay so we're looking at fixed base
number system then usually to represent
a number as big as a million you need
you know you it's the the the different
bases are the different registers are
all powers of a fixed base right 10 to
the 0 10 to the 1 10 to the 2 etcetera
so in order
represent a number like 1 million it
requires a very big dynamic range so you
need one register to increment every
unit and the other register is
incrementing every ten to the minus five
units right or ten to the five units
right it doesn't change for that and in
biology it's very difficult to find
variables that have like a big dynamic
range like that you know six orders of
magnitude is very difficult to find by
contrast if you use this modulo system
it's possible to have numbers that are
very close to each other right in fact
even adjacent integers are tend to have
very large Co prime factors and you can
construct quickly a code with a similar
capacity using this and also the the
representation is sort of widened across
all scales so if you go from the number
you know 45 representation looks very
similar to the representation for the
number 800,000 it looks different in
decimal it looks very similar in modulo
and then if you increment by one then
sort of that information is carried in
all of these all of these registers not
just not just a final one okay so in
other words if there's a lesion or like
a damage to any of the you know any of
these moduli it's kind of gonna be an
equal effect right you don't just some
lose one digit completely so some
robustness there's some whitening
there's also some another very
interesting property which is a property
of carry free arithmetic so in in fixed
base number systems if you add two
numbers ninety-seven and four you have
to of course take that spillover and
carry it over to the next register and
so on which means that the operation can
only be done in serial you have to first
do the ones and then only can you do the
tens and so on so they're they're k
digits you have it this takes order K
time okay by contrast with a modular
number system you just can add up all of
these in parallel all in one step
there's no carry over which is good
because it's parallel not serial okay so
I'm at Maddie I mean so even for a
computer scientist this could be your
useful thing and moreover for biology it
means that information doesn't have to
be moved from one set of grid cells with
one period to the next set of grid cells
with another pair you don't need these
long distance wires that then tell you
no carry the information circuitry to
make that happen each one is just
receiving will also you can put
increment
incrementing right in fact I think in
some chips there's some hardware devices
for like at least you know in the 90s I
think there was some hardware
chips built specifically using modular
arithmetic when they require a lot of
add operations for example in some of
these video video chips so so so
actually you know has the parallel
implementation it's kind of a useful
property okay
so then if we visualize now so this was
all this was integers let's talk about
real numbers right so in real numbers I
said the capacities and carries over but
we can visualize what's going on in the
code in this way so this code lives on a
torus right so we've got n phases each
of which is a circular variable right so
basically the code lives on the surface
of this n-dimensional torus and if we
start from the position say all zeros
phases and then as position like on this
X this this axis represents position
incrementing this way and as the X
increments then the phases increment and
this coding line wraps around this torus
okay and then as you keep increasing X
it wraps around some more and some more
and some more and so on and if this line
has you know finer resolution right
because you know everything has finite
resolution in the real world then it has
a certain thickness and at some point
it's gonna wrap around itself or it's
going to intersect itself at which point
then you're done right and that's the
capacity of the code and it turns out
that the capacity of that code is again
exponential in n the number of distinct
periods used over here so there's the
the sort of the range over which their
unique code word skills us this
characteristic size of the moduli lambda
with N in the exponent and beta depends
on detail on the choice the moduli but
very generic choices that moduli produce
this kind of exponential behavior you
don't have to choose special moduli it's
generic ok so so that's that's really
interesting and one thing I want you to
notice is that if we look at how these
coding lines curve around each other you
can see that really nearby locations
which are similar color are actually
interleaved by coding lines for very far
away locations so like red interleaves
with blue which interleaves with red you
know with green and so on so they're
sort of interleaving these very remote
position values or interleaving closely
two with each other in this coding space
ok which is an interesting property so
you might say well that sounds terrible
because
it means that you have an exquisite
noise sensitivity over the range are so
in fact definitely true so if you look
at you compute this are this full range
and you now start with a point x0 it
represented with the appropriate coding
word for that range here for that
position and then and then add a small
amount of noise with very small variants
to the codeword and then try to decode
over that range it actually puts you far
away in the coding space in fact usually
that metrically across because of this
interleaving property so it result from
this huge distribution of errors like
these black ones are the posterior
distribution sample posterior for a few
noise samples with with comparison I
just match a classic local population
code with the same number of neurons and
same noise and you can see that's
actually doing much better so this seems
like a terrible scheme but it turns out
that if there are small independent
errors okay so it seems like you know
these massive position errors are just a
terrible idea
okay but if one doesn't code and encode
over the whole and decode over the whole
range so you know this whole range big R
because it's exponential in n it's huge
in fact if astronomical for a modest
values of you know n of seven and you
know period lambda that are measured in
biology you get things like you know you
know a 10 to the 10 meters or or more
right which is huge so instead imagine
that the animal only ever cares to
encode and decode over much smaller
range R sub L some limited range that
still exponential in n but some
pre-factor row okay which is a small
number like point one or something like
that and now you just encode and decode
over that smaller range then it turns
out that if you now look at you know a
sample of the posterior distribution it
looks like so this is black is the is
the grid cell code green as the plate is
a classical population code and if you
look now the grid cell code is doing
much better
okay in the information rate in fact of
this code is this number row that you
put in here in in defining this limited
range right so you can pick it to be
some finite number and then one can get
this this result so it turns out that
the ratio of the fidelity of the grid
cell code to the classical population
code over these exponentially large
ranges is exponentially small so in
other words the grid cell code is doing
proportionately much better than the
than the place fell like code their
classical population codes yeah okay and
numerically one can one can verify that
that indeed there's an exponential gain
in doing this kind of coding even in the
presence of noise right so so in other
words it's possible to have an
exponential dynamic range in the
presence of noise and with the finite
information row okay so one other thing
to note is that you know if you look at
classical population code like place
cell like codes right which are sort of
very local then you know the posterior
distribution oh the likelihood of those
codes look like this green line the
likelihood of the grid cell code in the
presence of noise may look like multi
peaked but then if you have a prior on
continuity which is as you're walking
around you know that you can't move you
can't teleport or jump far away then you
can combine the likelihood with the
prior distribution like this red one
that imposes the continuity and then
it's possible to recover a very sharp
estimate of position from the grid cell
code but it doesn't help you the prior
doesn't help too much with the classical
population code so this is a case of a
very incoherent prior write to the prior
and the likelihoods have to be very
different from one another to see the
Gaye and it's sort of like the opposite
of quick you know of like you know
conjugate priors what you want to get
the same distribution here you want to
have maximally different distributions
right you're gonna have some locally
bomb distribution with very distributed
distribution that's quite different so I
want to just give you some intuition
over here so if you look at the
classical population codes
these look like low dimensional
embedding of code code words in this
high dimensional space like you know a
single curve like this and if we
consider a ball of unit noise here right
then a ball of unit noise has a
projection onto a one-dimensional line
that scales down like one over n and so
the fractional error from the code is
like 1 over square root of n it ok the
root mean squared error by contrast if
we look at the grid code the grid code
is actually this you know denser line
sort of like the space-filling curved
line but it's decimated so you basically
delete many of the lines you're only
looking at some set of lines within it
but still there's many many you know the
coding line length is like exponentially
long right with linearly many neurons
you get this exponentially wrong coding
line so now if you have a noise ball by
it like a neurons are noisy you have a
unit noise ball with the same number of
neurons
okay so now if we look at the projection
of that you know unit noise ball on to
the the line the fractional error around
the line from from a unit radius noise
ball is just it's exponentially small
right because the line is it's
potentially large and so the fractional
error is much smaller than okay so I
wanted to say some more things but I'm
going to stop here because I'm getting
close to the end of my time and I want
to just end with a with a couple of
points so I think these in my view are
the key features of the grid cell code
it simultaneously allows for robust
exponential capacity but at the same
time it's this linear code that
structure preserving or you know allows
for metric updating so you know so
you've got this you know capacity that's
you know big but robust and at the same
time you know you've got you know with
this combinatorial capacity you could
just choose random code words right you
could comment really choose code words
right like words and a dictionary you
have combination of letters and you can
get exponentially many code words but
the beauty of the scheme is that you
know the code word for X plus the code
word for another variable Y is the code
word for the sum of egg that's why it
has its property which is necessary for
this path integration the symmetric
updating of the code word so it's got
this beautiful structure to it
that's metric while at the same time you
know having this commercial capacity and
what's really interesting is even the
sort of metric updating but notice that
distances in real space are not
preserved in distances in the coding
space in fact they all these interleaved
coding lines far away points get mapped
close by and close by points get not far
away so these distances aren't preserved
and in fact this interleaving property
is what allows this combinatorial code
to actually be robust okay so it's sort
of like this this combination of these
three things right large capacity this
interleaving coding for robustness and
then finally this algebraic this very
nice time updating problem okay so I'll
just end the coding summary and I won't
get a chance to tell you about some of
these other features of spatial codes
but I'm very happy to discuss them
offline so the grid cell code can
generate unique representations for
exponentially many rate or the brains of
locations with linear million with
linearly many neurons it's capable of
metric updating
and one thing I want to note is that in
the case of grid cells the discovery of
these coding properties is largely
bottom-up so these were cells that we
discovered with no preconception to what
would be a good code right and then on
observation of these grid cell codes we
can do this series of mathematical
inferences and deduce these beautiful
properties of the code but it's not
something that we had hypothesized
before it's not some top-down view of
you know coding in the brain and I think
that's really interesting I think it's
exciting that there's a lot of scope
still for bottom-up discovery in
neuroscience so I'm just going to go to
my acknowledgment I'll stop there so
this work was done with my longtime
collaborator you're on Brock John but
Lasky is my PhD student who is in the
audience and he's here at Berkeley so go
talk to him if you need to talk to
somebody who does spatial
representations here ki-jong is a former
graduate student and samhita former
postdoc and both of them worked on this
as well and knocked ran with assignments
fellow here is also working on some of
these coding questions with me but
thanks very much
[Applause]
yeah okay that's that's a really great
question so um I'll say one thing so
maybe I can say two things so one thing
is there's two questions about the
formation of this kind of circuit one is
sort of on the developmental timescale
so animals are not actually born these
mammals leave mice are not born with
grid cells when they're born you can
record from these cells and they don't
have this nice tuning it emerges over
the course of many days as they explore
after their eyes open up when their pops
they explore the environment and then
slowly the circuit develops okay and so
John in the audience theory respond put
up your hand if you there there okay but
John has a model for this so but you
know again the model depends on things
called happy and learning or having
plasticity rules so these are rules for
how activity should influence
connectivity and and and and so it has
assumptions built in about the form of
those rules for how activity influences
connectivity but given some simple forms
of those rules this kind of connectivity
can emerge that can then produce
functional paths innovation behavior the
other answer the question is how do
neural circuits you know across
evolutionary time scale and different
animals you know develop to do have this
functionality I think it's a great and
interesting question
flies it turns out have this very
similar head Direction circuit as
mammals do it just this a series of
papers from three years ago and
continuing into the present showing this
circuit for head Direction cells that I
discussed today it looks to be very
literally present in flies so that's
probably not a conserved that's probably
an example of parallel evolution that
you know they have a very similar
circuit so maybe it's a case where
function is really strongly constraining
the properties of these of these
responses and so that's something that
we're trying to understand to buy you
know for example with the tool of
training neural networks you can
challenge them at the task give them a
tasks like some facial tasks to do and
look for the emergence of these
properties and see whether this is you
know in their science the best or in a
you know great solution to the problem
you know can I take that ok yes mmhmm
yes yeah I mean it's entirely possible
and I think that's a great question
right so those are exactly along the
directions which would have to follow
that thought and see whether indeed this
would be this unique solution or you
know very likely solution emerge with
its constraints yeah
[Applause]